Dans les années 50, on a découvert en Nouvelle Guinée,
près de l'Australie, une maladie
vraiment très bizarre : le Kuru.
Le Kuru, c'est une maladie qui se
manifeste par des tremblements,
des rires compulsifs,
et puis des crises de démence
et qui se termine par la mort du malade
au bout de quelques mois.
Ce qui est étonnant avec cette maladie, c'est qu'elle
touche uniquement une petite tribu de la région
qu'on appelle la tribu des Forés.
C'est un tout petit peuple, il y avait
environ 7 000 individus à l'époque,
mais on estime que chez eux, l'épidémie de Kuru
a fait environ 2 000 morts en une décennie.
C'est bizarre, non ? Une maladie
qui semble super contagieuse
mais uniquement pour une tribu, comment ça se fait ?
Pour le comprendre, il faut savoir
que dans la tribu des Forés,
ils ont un rituel un petit peu particulier.
Ils pratiquent le cannibalisme funéraire.
C'est à dire qu'ils mangent leurs morts, quoi.
C'est une manière pour eux de se nourrir de
la force physique et spirituelle des défunts.
Et notamment les hommes vont
plutôt manger les muscles
et les femmes et les enfants vont plutôt manger
les organes et notamment le cerveau.
Et on va voir que c'est ça qui est à l'origine
de la transmission de l'épidémie de Kuru.
Mais par un mécanisme qui est vraiment très étonnant
et qui diffère totalement de toutes les maladies
contagieuses qu'on connaissait jusqu'alors.
On a vu donc que le Kuru à l'air d'être une maladie
super contagieuse pour les gens de la tribu des Forés.
D'habitude, quand on a affaire
à une maladie contagieuse
Il peut y avoir plusieurs possibilités
concernant l'agent infectieux à l'origine.
Ça peut être un virus, une bactérie,
ça c'est assez classique,
ça peut être aussi un champignon, ou alors un parasite.
Si on prend l'exemple de la gale, c'est
une maladie de peau qui est très contagieuse
et qui est causée par un parasite acarien,
on peut en voir un ici.
C'est un parasite qui est assez gros
puisqu'il fait environ cent microns,
c'est-à-dire un dixième de millimètre.
Du côté des maladies qui sont causées
par des bactéries, on en connait plein,
on peut citer la tuberculose, qui est causée par
une bactérie qu'on appelle le bacille de Koch.
Ce qu'il faut noter, c'est qu'une bactérie c'est beaucoup
plus petit que, par exemple, le parasite de la gale
puisqu'une bactérie, c'est une simple cellule,
donc ça ne fait que quelques microns.
Et puis dernière possibilité quand on a une
maladie contagieuse, bien sûr, c'est un virus
comme, par exemple, dans le cas de la grippe ou du SIDA.
Un virus est vraiment minuscule, c'est environ
cent fois plus petit qu'une bactérie,
ça fait au maximum quelques centaines de nanomètres.
Les virus ont une forme, une structure,
ils peuvent contenir de l'ADN ou de l'ARN
mais attention, contrairement aux bactéries,
les virus ne sont pas des cellules,
C'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus simple.
Il y a même un débat assez technique
entre les spécialistes,
pour savoir si les virus, il faut les considérer
comme faisant partie du monde vivant ou pas.
En tout cas, si on en revient au cas du Kuru,
on peut se demander quel est l'agent infectieux
qui est à l'origine de la maladie
et de son caractère contagieux.
Est-ce que c'est un virus ?
Est-ce que c'est une bactérie ?
Ou est-ce que c'est un parasite qui cause le Kuru?
Eh bien, rien de tout ça.
La cause du Kuru, c'est un nouvel agent infectieux
qu'on ne connaissait pas jusqu'ici
et qu'on appelle un prion.
Un prion, c'est quelque chose d'encore
beaucoup plus petit qu'un virus
puisque c'est juste une protéine.
C'est-à-dire une simple molécule, finalement.
Alors pour comprendre comment une protéine
peut être à l'origine d'une maladie contagieuse,
il faut se pencher sur la manière
dont fonctionnent les protéines.
Les protéines, ce sont des molécules assez grosses
qui assurent la plupart des fonctions
des organismes vivants.
Dans votre corps, dès qu'il se passe un truc,
au niveau microscopique, il y a
des protéines qui font le boulot.
L'hémoglobine qui transporte l'oxygène,
c'est une protéine.
L'insuline qui sert à métaboliser le sucre,
Et les récepteurs du goût sur votre langue,
ce sont aussi des protéines.
Des protéines différentes, on en compte plusieurs
dizaines de milliers dans votre organisme,
et on est très très loin de savoir
à quoi elles servent toutes.
Par contre, ce qu'on sait, c'est que toutes ces
protéines, elles sont fabriquées dans nos cellules
un petit peu de la même manière, sous la forme
d'une chaîne de maillons élémentaires
qu'on appelle les acides aminés.
Les protéines les plus simples ont
quelques dizaines d'acides aminés
et les plus complexes peuvent
en avoir plusieurs milliers.
Et ce qui est très important, c'est que les protéines,
une fois synthétisées, ne restent pas
sous forme de chaîne, comme ça,
elles se replient sur elles-même pour
prendre une forme en trois dimensions
qui depend de leur séquence d'acides aminés.
Donc chaque type de protéine va avoir
une forme en 3D qui est caractéristique
et qui est essentielle puisque c'est cette forme
qui permet à la protéine d'assurer ses fonctions,
et l'action d'une protéine va dépendre de sa forme.
Ici, par exemple, vous pouvez voir
la manière dont on représente
la forme en trois dimensions
de l'hémoglobine, de l'insuline,
et puis de certaines protéines qui servent
de capteur du goût sur la langue.
À l'origine du Kuru, on l'a dit, il y a une simple protéine,
on l'appelle PrP pour Protéine à Prion.
Cette protéine, normalement, ne nous rend pas malade.
Elle est naturellement présente dans notre organisme,
c'est-à-dire qu'on la synthétise.
On connaît sa composition,
on connaît à peu près sa forme,
mais on ne sait pas très bien à quoi elle sert,
même si on pense qu'elle doit être impliquée
dans certaines formes de communication
entre les cellules.
Et ce qui fait la particularité de cette protéine PrP,
c'est qu'à part sa forme normale,
elle peut aussi se replier dans une autre forme,
qui est une forme anormale, qui est plus compacte.
Et c'est cette forme qu'on appelle prion.
A priori, on pourrait se dire que ce n'est pas bien grave,
si jamais, par hasard, une protéine PrP
se replie dans la mauvaise forme,
elle ne pourra peut-être pas fonctionner normalement
mais il y aura toujours les autres
qui seront là pour assurer le job.
Sauf que ce qui est diabolique, c'est que si jamais
une protéine prion, donc mal repliée,
rencontre une protéine PrP normale,
c'est à dire bien pliée,
elle la convertit et elle la met dans la mauvaise forme.
C'est comme si elle la pervertissait en lui
donnant une espèce de baiser de la mort.
Ce mécanisme de déformation on
ne le comprend pas complètement
mais il se manifeste surtout dans le cerveau.
Il semble que les protéines prions
mal repliées s'agrègent entre elles
et forment des espèces de fibres qui sont capables
de croître en attrapant des protéines
normales et en les déformant.
Et donc, on a une espèce de phénomène
de réaction en chaîne
qui transforme peu à peu les protéines PrP normales
en fibres de protéines mal repliées.
À force, ces fibres s'accumulent et conduisent
à la formation d'un tissu spongieux dans le cerveau
qui se manifeste sous la forme de zones,
qui ressemblent un peu à des trous.
C'est ça qui cause les troubles
neurologiques associés au Kuru
et qui finit par tuer les malheureux malades.
Toute cette histoire de cerveau spongieux
et de troubles neurologiques,
ça vous rappelle peut-être quelque chose :
la maladie de la vache folle.
Eh bien, la maladie de la vache folle est
aussi causée par une infection à prion,
qui est basée sur la déformation
de la même protéine PrP
et avec un mécanisme qui est vraiment
comparable à celui du Kuru.
On retrouve le même genre de maladie chez le mouton,
on appelle ça la tremblante du mouton
et chez d'autres mammifères.
Toutes ces maladies sont des maladies à prions
qui causent l'accumulation de tissus
spongieux dans le cerveau
et finissent par causer des troubles
neurologiques qui entraînent la mort.
Toutes ces maladies, on les désigne sous le nom
d'encéphalites spongiformes.
La raison pour laquelle il y a eu une épidémie
de vache folle dans les années 90
c'est dans le fond, la même que celle qui a causé
l'épidémie de Kuru dans les années 50 et 60.
Vous vous souvenez que les gens de la tribu
des Forés pratiquaient le cannibalisme funéraire.
Du coup, si quelqu'un mangeait le cerveau
d'un mort qui était infecté par le Kuru,
il se retrouvait à ingurgiter une grande quantité
de protéines PrP mal formées, des prions.
Qui du coup, venaient déformer ses propres
protéines PrP et enclenchaient la réaction en chaîne.
Pour la maladie de la vache folle,
il s'est passé la même chose,
vous vous souvenez peut-être que la
cause de l'épidémie, c'est le fait de
nourrir certains animaux avec de la farine animale
c'est-à-dire des restes de carcasses broyées
d'autres animaux qu'on avait déjà abattus.
Une forme de cannibalisme déguisé, quoi.
Il a suffi que les restes d'animaux
infectés se retrouvent dans la farine
pour que tout un cheptel soit contaminé.
Ce qui est fascinant avec ces maladies
c'est que ce sont des maladies
infectieuses, contagieuses
mais qui sont causées par un mécanisme très différent
de ceux dont on avait l'habitude avant comme
les virus, les bactéries, et les parasites.
Le prion est une protéine, une simple molécule
et pour le coup, on est sûr qu'elle
ne fait pas partie du monde vivant.
Mais pourtant, ce truc pas vivant arrive
à créer un mécanisme de contagion.
La compréhension de ce mécanisme a été
une petite révolution dans le monde de la biologie
qui a valu à son découvreur, le neurologue
américain Stanley Prusiner
le prix Nobel en 1997.
L'histoire pourrait s'arrêter là, et ce serait déjà fascinant,
mais ce qui rend ces maladies encore plus
effrayantes, c'est que les prions,
un, on ne peut pas les détecter directement,
deux, ils sont quasiment indestructibles
par les moyens habituels.
Par exemple, dans notre organisme,
normalement, on a des enzymes
qui sont capables de découper les
protéines pour les neutraliser.
Et bien, les prions résistent à ces enzymes.
Les prions sont aussi insensibles à la radiothérapie,
donc ce n'est pas la peine d'essayer.
Si vous voulez détruire un prion,
il va falloir y aller beaucoup plus fort.
Par exemple, quand on a des instruments
chirurgicaux qui sont contaminés par le prion,
on recommande de les mettre à 130°
pendant une heure, sous plusieurs bars de pression.
Quelque chose de beaucoup plus violent
que les moyens de stérilisation habituels
et aussi beaucoup plus violent, par exemple
que la pasteurisation qui se passe à 70°.
A titre de comparaison, le virus du SIDA,
qui est un virus assez fragile
on estime qu'il est détruit aux alentours de 60°.
Bref, le prion est un agent infectieux, contagieux,
très difficile à détruire, et impossible à repérer.
Ça fait peur, non ?
Et ce qui noircit encore un peu plus le tableau,
c'est qu'il peut y avoir des contaminations
d'une espèce à l'autre.
En fait, ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que la protéine PrP
est quasiment la même chez tous les mammifères.
Donc si un humain ingurgite, par exemple,
un prion provenant d'une vache,
il y a un risque que ce prion se mette à contaminer
ses propres protéines PrP humaines.
Et c'est comme ça que la maladie de
la vache folle a donné lieu chez l'humain
à une nouvelle maladie à prions qui est une variante
de la maladie de Creutzfeld-Jacob
et tout ça à cause de la consommation
de viande de bœuf
qui provenait d'élevages contaminés par la vache folle.
Et cela pas seulement pour ceux
qui mangeaient du tartare,
cuire sa viande, c'est pas vraiment
suffisant pour détruire les prions.
Depuis 1996, on a recensé plus de 200 cas
de cette nouvelle maladie à prions,
la variante de la maladie de Creutzfeld-Jacob.
A peu près les trois quarts au Royaume-Uni
et il y a eu, je crois,  27 cas en France.
Dans le même temps, on a compté
plus de 200 000 bovins infectés,
mais à titre préventif on en a abattu plus de 4 millions.
Depuis, tout ça a été bien maîtrisé notamment
par l'interdiction des farines animales
et on ne relève plus vraiment de
nouveaux cas chez l'humain
de la variante de la maladie de Creutzfeld-Jacob.
Sauf que...
on sait que ces maladies comme
le Kuru tuent en environ un an,
une fois que les symptômes sont apparus.
Mais la période d'incubation avant
que les symptômes apparaissent
peut durer entre 5 et 20 ans.
Voire peut-être plus.
On sait que chez les Forés, le cannibalisme a été interdit
par les autorités australiennes dans les années 50.
Et pourtant, le dernier cas de Kuru, on l'a relevé en 2005.
Et donc, ça a amené certains spécialistes
à conclure que la période d'incubation
d'une infection à prions
pouvait peut-être atteindre 50 ans.
Et si on était déjà tous contaminés ?
Si on portait déjà tous en nous des prions ?
Des protéines mal formées, qui peu à peu
transforment nos protéines PrP bien formées
et dont les symptômes neurologiques
vont se manifester dans 10 ou 20 ans ?
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Si vous voulez aller plus loin, vous pouvez aller lire
le billet de blog que j'ai écrit et
qui accompagne cette vidéo,
qui précise un certain nombre de choses
et qui notamment donne toutes
les sources que j'ai utilisées,
les publications scientifiques pour faire cet épisode.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à la partager.
Vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne,
vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux habituels, Facebook, Twitter.
Ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee,
merci beaucoup à ceux qui me soutiennent déjà.
Et vous pouvez aussi aller jeter un œil au bouquin
que j'ai écrit il n'y a pas longtemps,
édité chez Flammarion.
Voilà, merci et à bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos!